emanuel macrón se queda en el elíseo el
escrutinio da como ganador al actual
presidente sobre su rival la
ultraderechista marine lepén con 58 8%
se impuso en las presidenciales aunque
ganó el resultado fue menor al de la
contienda de 2017 cuando también se
enfrentó al epen en su discurso de
victoria desde el campo de marte anunció
que buscará la unión de la francia
polarizada además reconoció que no todos
sus votos fueron de adhesión a sus
políticas sino de oposición al epen
todos juntos tendremos que trabajar por
esa unidad que será la única que nos
permitirá vivir más felices y enfrentar
los retos que nos esperan
los años que vienen no serán tranquilos
con toda seguridad pero sí serán años
históricos y todos juntos sabremos
escribirlos para nuestras generaciones
pese a su holgada victoria es consciente
de las críticas a su gobierno crisis
como las manifestaciones de los chalecos
amarillos el manejo de la pandemia y la
guerra en ucrania por eso anunció un
cambio de este próximo quinquenio
por todo esto quiero junto a todos
ustedes afrontar los próximos cinco años
esta nueva era no será la continuidad
del mandato que acaba de terminar
sino la invención colectiva de un nuevo
método para cinco años que serán mejores
al servicio de nuestro país y de nuestra
juventud donde los funcionales
[Aplausos]
marine le pen recibió el 41 2 %
interpretó los resultados como una
victoria el resultado de esta noche
representa en sí mismo de todas maneras
una victoria sorprendente esta francia
tan olvidada nosotros no la olvidamos
créanme estamos más determinados que
nunca y nuestra voluntad de ayudar a los
franceses es aún mayor además de
anunciar que sería oposición de macrón
llamó a votar masivamente las
legislativas para hacerse con el
parlamento
noche lanzamos la gran batalla electoral
de las legislativas
[Aplausos]
librar esta batalla al lado del señor de
like con todos los que tuvieron la
valentía de oponerse al señor marco en
la segunda vuelta la extrema derecha
tuvo una votación sin precedentes en
estas elecciones aunque la abstención
fue la más alta desde los años 60